i don't know why they do but they do and
we should be
um blessed by it and i want to get
emotional about it
because that really hit me you know in
the right place
you know i i feel like we're doing this
in a vacuum
and people enjoy it i don't know why
i'll never know but you know i'll keep
doing it
and um i think you're very lucky george
i think that
you know i'm lucky to have met you
i think that um it was god's will
to have him you in my life i think that
you changed my life in an incredibly
positive way um i don't think that i
would have
the business that i have without your
contribution
i think that um this woman is very lucky
to have you and vice versa
you're gonna have a really happy life
and um congratulations
thank you sweet make me cry
i also want to say why are you are you
crying because you don't make me cry
that's all he'll ever get from me take
it in you might edit this out that was
real
you might have to edit this if the tears
are too much
this kid is a it represents
you know something i i really do believe
that it is a part of our family i
i do too you know in a weird way and
that
i have out of any kid that's ever been
born
there's something specific about this
situation that's
that hits close to home for me because i
knew this guy as an unfuckable [ __ ]
no i honestly this guy was like this guy
[ __ ]
you know it's crazy to even think that
that this guy penetrates you know what i
mean
but that he met somebody you know i mean
that
wanted to have a baby with him you mean
and that now this baby is coming
it just it just a complete and utter
um a spiritual message to me
saying that this is all a part of the
whole scheme of things
and it's um it just really is a
beautiful thing man and um
hopefully you know we could work
on other things together you know i mean
as the years go on um
how long i was gonna be babe i wouldn't
keep going
longer i got five points ready to beat
her no i want to keep going okay thank
you
this is my podcast all right
so let me finish by saying this all
right
rip it i knew it yes i was like
favorite say rip it yes thank you for
that that's it guys
that's it congrats short yeah i love you
guys
guys that was our george's baby shower
special
george i hope you uh appreciate my
decorating